for some insight on what's next for a
national health care we turn to Ron
Brownstein senior editor at the Atlantic
he's in our Washington bureau Ron good
morning good morning so whose failure is
this Ron's a Sean Spicer says Trump left
it all on the field do you think this
was a learning moment for the White
House I think it was first of all it is
difficult to think of another president
who suffered as big a legislative defeat
this early in their presidency I mean
you go back in the first hundred days to
lose something of this magnitude is I
think extremely rare if not entirely
unprecedented look there were tactical
problems but there were also strategic
problems the tactical problems were the
freedom caucus in the in the House
Republican the House Republicans were in
transition and not ready to govern the
president was energetic but somewhat
unfocused they simply did not have a
mastery of the policy details aren't
understanding about how changing some of
the policies could affect the
legislature dynamic for instance their
final changes moved some conservatives
toward them but they lost moderates they
fail to develop any institutional
support not only did conservative groups
oppose the bill but so did essentially
every major component of the medical
profession from hospitals to doctors and
you know there was also a choice that
was almost completely unremarked to
exclude Democrats from the beginning
which left them very little margin for
error and allowed each Republican
faction to have a veto but I would say
the bigger problem was strategic which
is that facts on the ground matter
President Obama's Affordable Care Act
gave coverage provided coverage of 20
million people and Republicans face a
basically a deadlock between
conservatives who felt the bill did not
withdraw coverage from enough and
moderates felt that went too far and
they learned as a final point they
learned their coalition is very
different than it was 20 years ago it
now includes a lot of lower middle
income older white voters who are
perfectly happy with government benefits
as long as it benefits them and
Republicans face the reality that this
bill imposed its highest costs on older
workers at a time when White's over 45
provided a majority of Donald Trump's
votes Iran the president and his
colleagues in Congress say they want to
quote move on but the question is can
they is that yeah politically feasible
at the freedom caucus it says they want
they still want a full repeal of
Obamacare can they leave this issue on
the field no I look I don't
think they have to move on there is no
possibility of a full repeal of
Obamacare let's let's remind everybody
that even if this had passed the house
yesterday you know the president said on
Thursday he was done negotiation to gun
negotiating that was really kind of
delusional because if it passed the
house he had just started negotiating
they would have to figure out a way to
get it through the Senate because by
moving it so far to the right in the
final hours in the house particularly by
repealing those essential health
benefits they guarantee that nothing
like that was going to pass the Senate
so that have to figure out a way to get
it through the Senate and even if they
did they would then have to figure out
how to get the house you except with the
scientists right and we're talking about
seven years the drumbeat over the repeal
of Obamacare can that drum beating just
stopped abruptly today yeah I think well
I think it's going to I think that I
think the drums are going to not
entirely silence I getting get a lot
quieter because I think the Republican
strategy now is to argue that Obamacare
will collapse on its own and there's no
doubt Obamacare has problems but it is
worth noting that in the same analysis
at the Congressional Budget Office said
with this bill would deny coverage of 24
million people the Congressional Budget
Office conclude that the Obama Obamacare
was not in a death spiral that it could
stabilize and produce stable insurance
markets over time you know as i like to
say the CBO said Obamacare is not going
to die of natural causes if it expires
is because somebody's going to hold a
pillow over its head well the president
has blamed the democrats for this
failure and he left the door open though
to work with him in the future I see
that happening I think it'd be very hard
it is a radically different vision of
his presidency right and one in which
there could be some potential but it
would require him to stand up to
elements of the Republican Party in a
way that he hasn't been willing to do I
mean the problem with Obamacare is in
the individual markets right it's in
it's in the portion of this for people
who brought buying private insurance
what the Republicans in the House wanted
to do is also repeal the expansion of
Medicaid which is provided over half the
coverage that is an absolute non-starter
for Democrats to take away health
coverage from that many lower-income
working people so he would have to
significantly change his policy goals
and then are there ways to talk about
stabilizing further the individual
markets possibly but i honestly think
that's very unlikely because it would
require such a confrontation with the
House Republican caucus now the question
is going forward does he
learn from this that's by excluding
Democrats from the beginning he gave
every faction of the Republican caucus a
veto that ultimately impinged on his
maneuverability that may be a lesson
that they could take into a tax reform
potentially well the tax reform question
is no less thorny or complicated Ron
Brownstein thanks as always for the
wisdom thank you